what here
on the best of days in the most innocent
of places
that destroyed the one person you love
most suddenly disappeared how long would
you search he must have loved her very
much I do admire his perseverance and
pretend I have a choice I have the power
either to let her go on living wherever
she is happy and never know anything
about what happened to her or she can be
dead and I get to find out everything
how far would you go I just want to know
what happened to Diane and I'm prepared
to do anything to find out how much
would you risk hello I'm the man you're
looking for I'm Barney
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey everybody its episode 62 of the 13
o'clock podcast and since it's October
and October we've been kind of doing I
mean you know maybe it hasn't been super
obvious but we have been doing kind of
like a creepy kind of theme and [__]
like that everything's a creepy thing
everything's creepy things but you know
I was just like you know I did it more
deliberately I guess this was actually a
topic that was suggested by more than
one person but I can't remember who like
suggested it but some people have
requested that we do like a creepy
disappearances kind of show like not
unsolved murders but people that just
vanished and they don't know where they
are
yeah unexplained dis unexplained
disappearances so I wanted to do one in
that vein and you know so I kind of
looked around for some ones that weren't
that I thought were kind of creepy I
mean obviously there's like a ton of
other ones I could probably just do a
whole podcast right that [__]
but I you know I picked ones that I
thought were kind of spooky so we're
gonna talk about some of those I got
like four or five of them if we can not
get to all of them we'll see how long it
takes already but before we do that
let's do our regular kind of shout outs
and housekeeping like we do at the
beginning okay my new book the faceless
villain is out in print and ebook so if
you want to read that then you can go to
Amazon and order it and if you like the
book please leave me a review that it
really helps a lot yes sales have been
good on hardcover yeah yeah I've already
sold a bunch of copies of the hardcover
so thank you to everyone yeah well we
thought hardcover actually so it's it's
a paperback yeah even a hard copy I
guess you could say yeah but no we
haven't gotten any reviews back on it
yet yeah I mean it's only been out they
probably have just received their books
yeah that's what I'm thinking right it's
only been up for a week and I'm still
working on the audiobook it's all
recorded I'm just doing the editing and
everything like that and like I said
once I know what the editing have to
upload it and then it goes through
audibles quality control system which
usually takes a minimum of ten days so
it's probably gonna be another couple of
weeks two or three weeks before the
audiobook is up but I'm sure I'm gonna
try and get it up as soon as possible
and like we said
or usually as soon as it goes live then
I get an email with 25 codes for free
downloads of the book yeah we've already
had requests so we'll get if you guys
were requested two copies we'll get to
you yeah
yeah so as soon as they come out but
like I said it'll be another two or
three weeks it's like you know I'm
having a lot of technical issues yeah
she had her she recorded the book and
then had to re-record it because of
microphone problems and yeah I think
yeah I think I ended up recording it
three times right like over this which
in a way was good cuz like when I was
recording it the third time it seemed to
go a lot easier cuz I almost haven't
memorized it that's just me as I've read
it somebody talks just moving the
microphone or moving the chair from what
you know that she that she reads from
even that is enough to screw up one
recording session yeah and sometimes
like I said you know in the like if our
kitten comes in and like kinda bumps
into the microphone and like she moves
it yeah and I don't realize you know and
then I get a record the next day I'm
like this sounds different so it's
really I had you know what I had to do I
had to put the microphone in the closet
yeah and get in the closet
and I had to like sit in the little
closet in my office will like with
pillows and like coats and stuff like
hanging and you know keep the closet
door closed so the kids yeah it's funny
I'll go in there to check on her
delighted to like feed her because now
she's in there working and I got a feed
Jenny no I'm like a gremlin yeah and I
see you're like in the closets are you
still in anyway it'll it'll be up soon
yeah and nothing is that we changed it
up you know they're some of the people
that have reviewed the books the
audiobooks before really were expecting
to like the normal Jenny telling you a
story type delivery and normally what
she would do it she'd get in there and
she'd read it and she'd really worried
about enunciation to make sure
everything's clear and all she's like
[__] it I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
tell read this like I might not notice
so much difference because like when we
were doing the podcast like I said
I do an outline but we don't script it
we don't really know what we're gonna
talk about exactly so sometimes we just
kind of like get on here and like
[__] and we don't even know where
this is gonna go and I feel like maybe
people like that so like I figured the
third time when I was recording the book
I was just like you know I'm not gonna
be because here's the problem when I
read aloud people have told me that I
read too fast because I read fast when
I'm reading to myself and so when I'm
reading out loud I'm gonna read fast and
I kind of talk to us and so when I was
doing my other audiobooks I tried to
deliberately slow down so people
wouldn't go with the [__] yeah yeah you
know what I mean but this sounds like
you know what [__] it as long as you can
tell what I'm saying
then I'm just gonna talk away I would
normally talk obviously I'm still
reading it but yeah and our shows are
not scripted that's why that's why the
very beginning of the show we have to
get like the housekeeping done yeah all
the little shout outs to everything that
we have to do we have to do it do that
first some of the older videos that we
have on there you know some people that
are not normal subscribers to jump in
damn get to the point I almost clicked
off you know but you know what if you're
that a didi [__] out you [__] out this
long-form
yeah just get the [__] out this this is
a long-form show we conceived this show
to be an hour long yeah for people that
were like me to be driving to work or
maybe they're jogging or they're laying
down in bed at night trying to go to
sleep cuz that's what I do I'll put a
show on yeah you know and if it's if
it's not at least an hour I won't listen
to it yeah you know under those
circumstances the show is not data the
show is a show yeah it's like any other
radio show and like I said you know I
was actually I wanted to comment on this
I think somebody commented on I think it
was our animal arraign Warren show maybe
yeah and I'm not sure if there I
couldn't tell if they were being
sarcastic but they were like well I must
click this off too much talking yeah
yeah so I comments and it's like well
next time we'll try to impart the
information to you via telepathy yeah
you should just be an hour of silence
with us just sending some thought waves
on our on our real popular shows that
kind of went viral you know they have
7000 views I mean we have people that
are not regular listeners and you should
see the [__] incredible [__] we got
to put up with them and it's YouTube
YouTube comments section is kind of like
it's kind of purgatory or hell it's like
you're hearing a demons from hell
although I say stupid [__] that really I
mean considering the subject matter that
we do and stuff like that we really
don't get that many stupid comments um
not that many
you know what got a lot of stupid
comments the Skoll experiment people
that really wanted this whole
experiences to be true got in there and
talked about what idiots we were and
that you know that we're afraid that
we're afraid that that seances are real
yeah man I went to a through a [__]
poultrygeist episode alright I'm not
afraid of [__] I'm not afraid of
ghosts seance okay I've been through the
poltergeist that's it's terrifying when
it's yeah and roll poltergeist when
you're 13 when ya when you're 13 and
you're seeing adults lose their [__] you
know talking about although what's
happening yeah it's it's that shit's
[__] you know changes it shakes your
foundation yeah sure yeah let's see what
else what else do we have to do oh I
just put up a movie review for
Videodrome so check that I love that we
did a good show I think it's a good show
yeah we had a good time and also I want
to give a shout out to our newest
patreon patron Kieran thank you very
much thank you thank you very much again
to Dean Dean you are you're like a
heavy-lift Ramanujan rad you're the Lou
Ferrigno no you're the Arnold
Schwarzenegger the liver okay just like
you know here's 25 bucks you know here's
20-something bucks you know he's yeah
pursue that yeah
so you gave that on PayPal and if you
would like to do the same then go to
patreon.com/scishow to new clock podcast
give us a small monthly donation or you
can go to the blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's a
little PayPal link in the sidebar
and you can give a one-time PayPal
donation yeah I think I send it here and
that's in the little description box to
you I always put links and [__] down
bottom of my super long descriptions
kitchen everyone right there and also
this coming weekend is spooky Empire
yeah so if you're in the Orlando area
and want to go where is that what did I
say I was at the Hyatt Regency oh yeah
it's not an international drive unit
right you know how the internet works
you can find it word it yeah first I
thought they're talking about oh btw
Orange Blossom Trail yeah in there all
the hookers are yes Orange Blossom Trail
yeah I want to say look is that rude you
don't see the hookers on OBT no these
are not to talk to you yet no no
yeah these the Laura streetwalker yeah
yeah I have that ass hanging out of the
bottom and it's not the half you want to
see you don't want to see either you
don't want to see either half well I
said well I used to work at at a place
off of OBT so I used to drive on OBT
every morning and there are still
hookers walking on it like 7:30 8:00 in
the more I guess getting the getting the
guys that are like oh can I have a quick
blow job on the way to the job hook you
got a hook yeah it's illegal in Florida
of course but they just can't keep up
with it they got to catch them well they
don't think they care it no I don't
think so it's not illegal to like walk
up and down the street yeah even if you
look like yeah you know it's going on
yeah that's obvious all right and also
next week's episodes our Halloween
episode so you're kind of running out of
time yeah if you want to send some
Halloween stories I've got a [__] ton so
I might have enough for an episode I'm
not really sure depending on how fast I
read them but if you want to send one
then please get it to me very quickly
because we're actually going to do I'm
gonna try and do the Halloween episode
ahead of time because usually we do
these shows we record them over the
weekend but next weekend we're going to
be at spooky Empire all weekend so we're
not gonna have time so I'm gonna get
some video footage of that yeah we'll
put that up on the show yeah we
definitely should
and so I'm definitely gonna try and put
together the Halloween episode
time before Friday yeah so if you have a
story then please get it to me as
quickly as possible you can email it to
me at grave cake at gmail.com or you can
message me on the 13th o'clock Facebook
maybe what we ought to do is you ought
to we had a video records a lot of that
goes on and then we'll compile it into
into a show yeah we could do that we'll
put up a video show yeah if we get some
good footage we can yeah we can do that
we can just edit you know getting boring
spots out yeah see what's going on
yeah I'm sure some these guys on here
want to see those girls probably yeah
the costume sir you were pretty good
last time
yeah but you know what my favorite
costume was last year somebody dressed
up like the chick from Mars Attacks oh
yeah it was our friend yeah yeah yeah
what's her name Alex no yeah we yeah we
saw you know the chick from Mars Attacks
would like the huge beehive and that red
and white dress with the curly man we
haven't seen her around in a long time
her and her husband yeah I know what was
her name again I can't remember [__]
okay all right so I think that's all the
housekeeping we had this episode so
let's get to some creepy disappearances
now like I said I kind of there's so
many I could pick from but I kind of
picked ones that I thought were creepy
earth had like some kind of creepy
details and the first one I want to talk
about is actually this is a pretty well
known case the case of Tara calico the
what Tara calico that's her name okay
now this happened that's a hooker named
Tara calico yeah let's go west hooker
named that I was saying that's you know
then it sounds like it is kind of yeah I
think that sounds like a character like
an acquaintance exactly exactly
all right but anyway okay so it's
September 1988 and Tara lives in New
Mexico and what she usually does she
usually rides her bike along state route
47 now for a while her mom had been
riding with her but her mom kind of
stopped
riding with her because she's like well
I kind of feel like there's been like a
car like following us or you know
following her and so she kept trying to
get Tara to like take mace and stuff
like that in tears like man whatever
chill out it's fine now in this
particular day which was September 20th
she went out to ride her bike and she
specifically told her mom just like now
if I'm not back by noon then come and
find me because she knew the route that
she took how old is this girl with dog
much she's 18 I think or somewhere
around there
so she says if I'm not back by noon then
come to you come along the route fine
because you know I'm supposed to go play
tennis with my boyfriend at 12:30 well
noon comes and goes and Tara does not
return so her mom who's name is Patti
goes and drives along the route they
don't find her now
she calls the police and reports Tara
missing all that the police find along
the route is they find Tara's Walkman
and a broken cassette tape they don't
find the bikes they don't find a bicycle
they don't find her nothing now some
people had seen her riding her bike that
day like this are every day
no one saw anyone take her although a
few people said that they did see a
light-colored pickup truck with like a
camper shell on it yeah it makes sense
that was that might have been following
her that was like along that same Road I
mean I have a place to throw that
bicycle yeah cuz they never did find
that yeah so I was thinking van or you
know maybe pickup truck yeah camper on
the back it was and it was an older
pickup truck it was like 1950s style
pickup truck maybe a Ford they say now
no one hears a damn thing all they found
was a Walkman of the tape that's it no
one hears a damn thing for almost a year
then in June 1989 there's a convenience
store in Port st. Joe Florida which you
know if you if you know your geography
is very very far from New Mexico there's
a woman and she's coming out of a
convenience store and she sees a
Polaroid picture laying in an empty
parking space this Polaroid picture
shows a young woman and a little boy oh
I know the photo yeah tied up and gagged
yeah now this woman that found this
photo she said that she
thought that there had been the classic
white windowless van rook parked in that
space where the photo was found
she said she kind of saw the guy that
was driving it she just said he looked
like he was in his 30s he had a mustache
that was about it now she gave the
description of the car and everything
like that and the police looked for the
guy but they didn't find anybody now
they said that the picture must have
been taken after May 1989 it was found
in June 1989 because Polaroid said that
that that type of film wasn't available
before that time right now this photo
was put on the show a Current Affair you
remember that show yeah yeah in like a
month later and some people that saw it
said that it looked like the girl looked
like Tara calico mhm
and the weird thing too is that in the
photo you can see there's like a
paperback book later and it's the book
my sweet Audrina by VC Andrews right
which was flowers in the Attic Flowers
in the Attic tip yeah that series and
they said that that was that that was
Tara's favorite book that particular one
or her Flowers in the Attic was her
favorite book alright so they showed the
picture to Tara's parents and her
relatives and stuff like that they think
it's her but they're not entirely
certain now the little boy that's in the
picture there was a boy that went
missing also from New Mexico in April of
1988 named Michael Henley now Michael
Henley's parents saw the picture on
Current Affair and they thought that
that was their kid but the weird thing
about that is that later on in 1990 they
actually found Michael Henley's body but
it was like out in the zuni Mountains
right and it was seven miles from where
his family had been camping when he
disappeared right so they actually don't
think that Michael Henley was murdered
but that he just kind of wandered off
from the campsite and just died of
exposure got lost or whatever now
they're not certain they've never
identified that kid though no I mean you
know they found Michael handler right
they don't know who that kid in the
picture
that [__] that wasn't the kid in the
face yeah it was probably not even
though the mom said it was but you know
it sorry you know you want that to be
your kid you want your kid to be alive
so you know I can understand and they're
not really sure that that girl was
calico yeah they're not certain about
that either I bet you that was a staged
photograph joke you know they're they're
playing around in the house and you know
I mean then they they tie each other up
somebody takes a picture it could be
think about it if you had killed those
people and you took a picture of it you
wouldn't lose that photo you wouldn't
even carry that thing around well yeah
why would it be in the van right that
just seems like a weird and then it have
a very weird thing to lose yeah a serial
killer wouldn't do that I don't think
unless they were like toying with the
family or something and left it there on
purpose
which no that's I would think that
there'd be a big chance that the photo
on the ground would go unnoticed yeah
that's what the serial killer would
think so he would probably more apt to
send it to authorities 20 years later
after the polaroid picture was found the
police officers in Port st. Joe where
the original Polaroid have been found
they got letters in the mail and in this
letter
there was a printed picture of another
little boy and he had like a black
rectangle like drawn over his mouth and
marker like you know what I mean like
like they were saying it was tape right
I don't think they ever figured out who
that kid was either right so people
messing around that I think it was it
says like according to the Wikipedia
page these letters they kind of they
were received at the same time that this
psychic had contacted police and she
said oh I used to work with Tara calico
in California in a strip club what and
she got murdered okay and then this
psychic says she's buried somewhere in
cap in California and told the police
where it was but they dug there and
there was nothing
right now apparently there were two
other Polaroids that have kind of
surfaced over the ensuing years that
could both be Tara calico but they're
very blurry they don't really know and
like I said even the original photograph
like Scotland Yard said they did a photo
analysis and they said yeah that's Tara
but then the Los Alamos lab did one and
said that was probably not her
the FBI's test was like inconclusive
they couldn't tell if it was her and
like when you look at the photo and look
at other because there are a lot of
other like you know school photos of her
and stuff like that you can't really
tell if that's the same girl or not yeah
and it's just kind of so weird because
nothing ever came of it it's like all
these pictures turned up and stuff like
that no one knows who they are no one
knows why they were left there
no one knows any of that [__] no arrests
no nothing I kind of think that what
happened was Miss calico just got
abducted off the roadside and killed I
bet you all those other photos have
aren't unrelated they might be yeah and
I mean because it seems strange that it
happened and you know that the photo was
found in Florida I mean yeah now some
Kyle I think that photo that was found
out there in Florida I've seen that
photo yeah it's very famous yeah and it
you know those kids don't look stressed
out at all
they look well-fed they don't even look
scared yeah I think it might have been
you know three brothers and sisters yes
far cousins and way of playing around
with a camera one of them - playing
kidnapper yeah and I don't know why I
mean that photo became nationally famous
I don't know why you didn't come forward
saying oh yeah that's that's us just
part of the gag here they thought they
were gonna get in trouble or maybe like
I said it was just somebody maybe they
forgot they took that photo they grew up
a little you know they grew up and yeah
it was just in there somebody
there there actually was a theory going
around that this truck that was
following her were people that she knew
like from school and that they
accidentally hit her on her bike but
then tried to cover up the crime without
throwing her in the truck and so some
people yeah so some people have said
that - that was just an accident there
have been some weird photos in relation
to serial killers ever this one serial
killer I forgot what his name was but he
was he used this teenage boy to go out
and capture these other teenage boys and
he time up to a bored one on either side
and kill him over a period of time well
they found a photograph in his
possession of a little kid you know at
least meant me six or seven maybe a
little bit young and he's tied to that
board that torture board that he used
and next to him a bunch of tools and
well they never have identified that kid
nor if they found his body and they they
found all the rest of the bodies and
evidently you know the kid must have
been from the area and there wasn't any
missing kids from the area so you know
they don't know that like freaks me out
yeah like who was that kid yeah what
happened to him could it be that that
was just some kid that he that he found
and just took that picture and that's it
let him go because he thought it was too
risky to kill him yeah or you don't know
yeah they never found the kid he wasn't
buried with all the other ones strange
yeah yeah yeah people that were an
object doesn't apply people that were
missing their kids could could an idea
yeah they said they know that's not our
kid so who were the parents yeah weird
weird yeah they're gonna a couple cases
like that word kids over like you know
like little Lord Fauntleroy which is in
my new book and it's like they fished
this kid out of a quarry or something
and he had like nice fancy clothes on
and all this other stuff no one ever
came nobody ever identified well if he's
never identified never reported missing
it's a problem always the parents
probably it's always the parent yeah
yeah so they kind of reconvened the task
force in 2013 to kind of reopen the Tara
calico case but so far nothing they have
no idea what happened to her
that's like nobody ever found or
anything like that now the next case I
want to talk about this one is actually
pretty weird there's not a huge amount
of information about it online but it's
it's just kind of weird in the in the
details that were left over now this is
the case of kornev malinovski and
annette sagres corner malinovski she was
about 26 years old I think and she lived
in the caretakers house at Mount Holly
plants a plantation in South Carolina
because her husband was the caretaker of
this of this plantation now heard her
husband they had three kids she had a
daughter named Annette sagres and then
her and the new husband whose name was
Steven they had two sons together now
her and Steven had a fight one evening
like an argument and it was a couple
days before Thanksgiving this was 1987
and apparently between 11:00 and 11:30
p.m. she went for a drive to calm down
and she never came back now the next day
she worked at a convenience store and
her boss didn't know where she was and
went to see what happened to her
he found her car parked in front of the
mountain Holly plantation it was all
locked everything like nothing otherwise
unusual but koruna was gone and they
never found out what happened to her now
the weirdest thing is that almost a year
later in October of 1988
Karnas daughter Annette she went out to
wait for her school bus in the morning
7:00 a.m. she and her little dog was
sitting next to her multiple witnesses
are standing there waiting for the bus
the bus comes at 7:20 and she's gone all
that's left is a note there's like a
little note that's written in pencil and
the note says dad
momma came back give the boys a hug hmm
and the it looked like it was written
like handwriting analysis analysts said
that it looked like it was written by
Annette sagres a little girl so the dad
because he didn't know that the girl was
missing until later that afternoon
because he thought she was at school so
he came home and he's like where's the
kids so then he went to the bus stop and
he found the note now they don't know
they think that she did write the note
but they don't know if someone made her
I think so I think somebody fooled her
with like under duress that's kind of
I'm feelin like two because now and I
read something about this on reddit
we're like a bunch of people were
talking about this case and somebody
made an excellent point they said you
know a little girl she was like how old
was she like eight nine ten that like
that yeah 11 she was 11 good
he's like would she write give the boys
a hug wouldn't she say my brothers why
would she get her to the boys that
sounds like an adult talking around you
know what I mean maybe not but that does
sound kind of plausible it sounds like
it was dictated to her or somebody told
her to write that told it yeah I think
somebody did her to write that because
obviously someone must have picked her
up in a car because she was gone in like
20 minutes
cuz she was standing there and then the
bus came 20 minutes later she was yeah
some somebody said that you know hey I
found your mom that type of deal that's
kind of what I feel like right and some
people said oh maybe her mom came back
for her but I'm like yeah but why didn't
she come back for her other two is she I
can't leave I can't leave you know no so
well here just write a note write this
and you know that's kind of what I feel
that happened I feel like it was some
creep that lived locally and knew that
my mom was gone yeah because it was a
pretty famous case at the time yes so he
smelled the weakness so yeah he just
went by and said oh hey I know where
your mom is you know just leave a note
for your dad I'll be fine I'll take you
to your mom and then you know might have
been the guy who might he might have
killed her yeah I'm not even the same
guy that killed the mom
yeah might have been yeah I mean I I
kind of thought like when you originally
hear about it you kind of think oh maybe
it was the husband but I don't know it
doesn't really seem friend of the family
maybe my family killed the mom and the
daughter yeah it might have been but the
strange thing is that after Annette
disappeared Steven the dad
he actually he went and married someone
else and had more kids and stuff like
that but the kids that he had with
coroner malinovski he like gave them up
like they were they were fostered out
like to a foster home and then they were
adopted like he gave up his parental
rights to them which I thought was very
odd hmm Sammy had some kind of mental
breakdown couldn't take care of him for
a while maybe that's what it was like
maybe he couldn't stand to look at that
Murni well I don't know what the deal
was with that but I just I thought
maybe what year was this again corn it
disappeared in 87 and a net to Savannah
in 88 maybe he didn't have a really good
marriage with his first wife anyway he
was like yeah screw these kids I'm
starting over and starting over I raced
this cold dudes yeah it does kind of
sound like that yes I don't want to
blame him I mean you know there's no
evidence that he killed the wife not
that I ever saw I don't think most
people think it was some kind of random
I think it was a random thing and his
reaction was well I'm starting over
yeah well so much yeah so much these
kids yeah that's pretty or maybe it was
maybe he'd lost his mind yeah I mean
that couldn't take care of him yeah
maybe he figured they needed a mother
and he wasn't a motherly type yeah well
it doesn't think about a lot of these
kind of like missing-persons cases it's
like there's really no where to end them
because they never found them they were
idea what happened to them just weird
stuff just weird stuff that happens it's
like a mystery we're actually at the
halfway point yeah we're at the halfway
point and we're gonna take a break right
now and I have actually like three more
cases I want to talk about if I have
time we'll see what we can make time
yeah we can we can make time or whatever
and so we're gonna take a short break
right now we'll be back in just a few
minutes
[Music]
okay and we're back talking about creepy
disappearance mm-hmm
now here's another one that happened
this actually happened in Florida again
Florida yeah doesn't involve a man no
this is not a Florida man all right this
is the case of died an audit now she was
actually 40 years old over the hill the
last time she was seen was on April 10th
1998 she was walking around outside of
her house but 11:00 in the morning
later that day she was seen walking
along us 19 and that was the last time
anybody ever saw her two days later her
mother got a message on her answering
machine
that was from Diane all the message said
was help help let me out and hey gimme
that I remember that as though someone
was trying to take the phone away from
her I remember it was like sounded like
so okay the caller ID on the phone call
all it said on it was star light they
called the number back and obviously
nobody answered and the weird thing
about this is that you think that they
would have done more investigation like
what is star light it sounds like a
bowling alley or something like that but
evidently they never turned up anything
like even if they did like go
investigate this starlight place or
whatever it was but that's just that's
the word that came up on that caller ID
so they don't know like okay so a couple
days after the phone call they were kind
of searching around the side of us 19
and looking for clues and something like
that and they found a finger yeah which
later was revealed to belong to Diane
okay now I don't know if it was the
whole finger or just the fingertip I
think it was just like the the tip of
the pinky finger nothing like that so
yeah they found that now the thing about
Diane is that she had been okay up until
the late 80s when she started having
mental problems and manic depression and
she had to start taking medication she
had two children but they were taken
away and her husband
divorced her and she had some problems
with alcoholism and things of that
nature
now she had been Baker acted many times
so they don't know if someone like took
advantage of someone you know in a
vulnerable situation in that kind of way
but the weird thing is that she actually
like people did see her like she was
seen in a restaurant around April 10th
which is about the day she went missing
somebody said they saw her in a
restaurant somebody saw her the next day
in another restaurant eating lunch
evidently she was alone I don't know and
then that was the day before they found
her finger then this is this creeps me
out two weeks after she went missing
somebody found like inside one of those
like ice machine freezer thing yeah
convenience store in Odessa Florida yeah
they found a plastic bag with a bunch of
her clothes in it yeah creepy yeah now
nothing happened until 2000 and then
safety the st. Petersburg Times ran a
story like kind of an update on it and
then the day after that at the same
convenience store in Odessa
there was another plastic bag and
someone had written Diane on it hmm and
inside it was a stick of eyeliner and a
thing of pink lipstick a thing of
toothpaste and a little bottle of taboo
perfume they don't know if that stuff
was hers or if somebody just put it
there like it's some kind of weird sick
joke or something like that the weird
thing about it though is that in every
single source I read about says this it
says this bag that was in this
convenience store was found by Diane's
brother's girlfriend weird like how did
that happen I don't know like was it put
there specifically for her to find it
did they know she was gonna be there
like what the [__] did she put it there
I don't know and it's like nobody I'm
like that nobody like goes more into
that and I'm like I'm kind of curious
about why it was somebody that was
related to her that found it in that
Romanian store but he's not [__]
sounds like a conspiracy it really does
you know so the mom thinks maybe I mean
because Diane had was manic depressive
or bipolar disorder or whatever like
maybe someone took advantage of her and
something like that she was also seen at
the coral sands motel and it so happened
that the guy that managed this motel who
was named Gary Evers was later charged
with a murder not of her but he actually
shot a man after an argument that's
where he was evicted so they don't know
if that's not a second yeah that's it's
not kind of the same MO so they don't
know if he had anything to do with her
disappearance all they're saying is she
somebody said that they saw her at that
motel away shortly it could be something
real simple maybe she just had a
psychotic break she just became homeless
and she she did medication with her and
she just wandered wandering around you
know with bags of clothing and put maybe
she put him in the icebox for
safekeeping you know because he's she's
nuts yeah they should be that just
homeless vagrant you know
although finger someone could that might
have hadn't happened by accident maybe
she did that to herself
you don't know good and maybe she they
were just you know with bomb on bomb
violence like I said my cell phone on
Victor yeah oh yeah so we don't remember
that video fed called bumfights regatta
guy would pay two bombs to fight each
other and he recorded on video and put
it up on YouTube and they told him to
stop stop doing that even though the
bombs wanted to do it they were making
good money bomb fighting it one bomb and
throw the one bomb through the other
bomb into into a shopping cart and
through it pushed him down like four
flights of stairs
no safety net no safety now that relates
back to the what we were talking about
out our video drone perfect like
something that they would put that max
Wright would put on his chair okay
and then yeah evidently is very popular
yeah all right so the next case I'm
determined that this one is actually for
some reason this one is actually super
popular and there's like a ton of like
[__] conspiracy theories about it and
this one is the girl's name is Maura
Marie and this happened in Massachusetts
in 2003 2004 now Maura Marie was a
college student at Amherst she was
studying nursing and evidently she kind
of had a little bit of a minor criminal
past stolen credit card and she order
food was stolen credit card and stuff
like that you know nothing major but so
okay the weird just started in February
of 2004 she has a job on campus like as
a security guard like to help pay for
classes right now she's at her job one
night and she's talking to her sister
Kathleen about you know
Kathleen's relationship problems on this
other stuff around 10:30 p.m. she's
sitting at her little security desk and
she starts like having a crying fit like
she sounds like a nervous breakdown type
of thing or whatever now her supervisor
comes to the desk and says that she's
just sitting there with an open book in
front of her just staring off into space
and that she won't answer any of his
questions or anything like that now he
asked what's wrong with her and all
she'll say is my sister that's all
she'll say she doesn't say anything
about what they were talking about the
phone or nothing like that so they
thought that was a little weird but
whatever so he takes her and takes her
back to her dorm room everything's fine
now a couple days later her father comes
to visit her and they go out looking at
cars they go to dinner than whatever now
after they get back the father staying
at a hotel because he's from somewhere
else and the end Mora borrows his car to
go to a party now on the way home from
the party she hits a guardrail and does
$10,000 in damage to her dad's car damn
so the cops take her back to the hotel
now
weirdly there is an accident report but
it doesn't appear that they did field
sobriety tests on her although I'm
assuming she was drunk because she was
coming home from a party and you know
read of cars so now $10,000 for the
damage on
our car was this that's been a Lexus or
so is it Corolla it was a Toyota Corolla
yeah my name rose it they cost that much
well she hit really hard yeah I had a
Corolla 1985 this is 2004 so Toyota
Corollas were more expensive into those
yeah it sounds like she pretty much
total to say but so the next day I guess
the dad well I'm sure the dad was mad
but whatever but he was like well the
insurance company will cover it or
whatever he picks up a rental car and he
drops more off back at the campus
apparently there was some kind there was
a phone call from the dad's phone to
Maura's boyfriend and it was only a
couple of minutes but nobody knows if
the dad called or she used his phone or
whatever so Maura goes back to school
and her dad goes back to doing his dad
stuff and she and he tells her okay
we'll go and pick up the accident claim
forms from the Registry of Motor
Vehicles and we'll sort all this [__]
out right and then there was some other
[__] like they know that she had used
her computer to search for directions to
Burlington Vermont to various places in
Vermont so they think she was going
someplace but they don't know why and
they don't know why she didn't tell
anyone
so she evidently had texted her
boyfriend and said I got your messages I
just didn't want to talk to anyone I'll
call you tomorrow or something like that
so apparently she packs up her car and
then she takes off she takes 280 dollars
out of an ATM now I don't know if that
was all the money in her account because
one source said it was all the money in
her account the other one didn't specify
it just said she took out 280 dollars
then and she was alone they have footage
of her at the ATM they also have footage
of heard a liquor store buying forty
dollars worth of booze hmm including a
box of Franzia wines and vodkas and
Palouse very
other things now she did pick up the
accident report forms so she did do what
her dad said so evidently she was
planning coming back on coming back
because she didn't have those so
evidently she got on interstate 91 and
started heading north now they said that
she called on her cell phone she called
her check her voicemail at 4:30 7 in the
afternoon but that was the last time her
cell phone was ever used a few hours
later in New Hampshire this woman hears
a thump outside her window and she goes
to look out and she sees that a car has
hit a snowbank and it's all [__] up
and she sees a girl walking around the
car she calls the cops no another person
who was a school bus driver he drove by
the accident and he stopped to help and
he asks her you know were you okay do
you need help or something like that
she's like please don't call the cops I
already called triple-a now this guy
said there's no cell phone reception out
here so I knew that she didn't call
triple-a and triple-a has no record of
her calling regardless so he heads back
to his house and calls the police
now police get there only a few minutes
after the call they get there at 7:46
and she's gone all they find now all her
[__] was still in the car like her debit
card credit card her cell phone was gone
she took those with her but
significantly her cellphone debit card
credit cards were never used after that
because you know they can track if
they're used they never were after that
what they all they found in the car now
the car was um it wouldn't run like the
the when she hit the snowbank the
radiator went into the fan and it was
alright so the windshield was cracked
both airbags had deployed mmm the car
was locked inside and outside the car
there were red stains which was actually
red wine from the Box rose the box was
all [__] up in the backseat he they
also found a triple-a card
they found the blank accident report
forms and various other things makeup
jewelry a couple sets of driving
directions to a couple different cities
in Vermont and you know
few other things like her favorite
stuffed animal a book about mountain
climbing [__] like that the lasts what
they think is the last sighting of her
happened between 8:00 and 8:30 there was
a guy driving along route 112 and he saw
what looked like a young woman walking
really quickly on foot now this was four
to five miles from where the accident
was said she was wearing like a dark
coach in a black backpack and a light
hood and they think that was the last
time anyone saw her so another weird
thing that I forgot to mention that in
the tailpipe of her car like the muffler
tailpipe of her Saturn there was a rag
stuck in there
yo rag in a tailpipe trick yeah that's
almost like the old banana in the
tailpipe yeah or the potato yeah so
after that she was considered a missing
person the weird thing is that okay so
they went back to her dorm room on
campus and she had packed up her dorm
room like she had taken the art off the
walls she had like [__] in boxes and
stuff like that and there was a there
was a printed out email like on top of
some of the boxes that was either to her
boyfriend or from her boyfriend that
indicated that they were having problems
in their relationship
they're not sure if she was like
deliberately taking off or if she went
somewhere to commit suicide or something
like that like her family thinks that's
unlikely right and it does sound a bit
unlikely because why would she have
picked up the accident forms and all
that other [__] if I was just gonna take
off
it just seemed really weird you know and
the fact that she that all she bought
and like I said I guess it would make
more sense if the $280 that she took out
of the cat that was like all her money
all right I don't know if it was or not
like one source I I saw said it was all
her money but the other one didn't
really specify that's a weird story the
only other weird thing was that her
boyfriend was flying to Amherst to like
help out in the investigation or
whatever and you know they make you turn
your cell phone off while you're in
flight but when he landed he had a
voicemail and all it was he said it
sounded like her crying and that's all
it was and it was only like
less than a minute rock along and the
weird thing is that this the call was
traced to a calling card that had been
issued to the American Red Cross yes so
what the [__] happened to this woman I
don't know like this is like it's such a
bizarre and and the weird thing is for
some reason this case in particular
really seems to have like captured the
Internet's imagination because there's
fuc tons of crazy conspiracy theories
about what happened to her you know none
of them is dumb is like you know alien
abduction but some of them are saying
like it's like here's this one guy okay
in 2012 and this was about seven years
after the disappearance someone going by
the name 112 dirtbag which route 112 was
what she disappeared from an dirtbag
like her dad her dad had said in the
media I think she got kidnapped by a
bunch of dirtbags going on with so
someone going by 112 dirtbag put up a
video of just himself looking very
creepy like laughing and [__] like that
and then a guy that wrote a book about
the case he looked was like super into
it he evidently got an email and the
subject line said stopped looking and
then in the body of the email it was
just coordinates you know I mean it's
like it's just creepy [__] like that
yeah and I'm just trolling that's what I
mean I think that's probably all
trolling and some people have said oh
you know she she had a tandem driver
because what they had bloodhounds come
to the scene and like track to see if
they could find out where she went yeah
now the bloodhound followed a trail but
the trail stopped in the middle of the
road she got a car which led them to
believe that she had gotten into a car
so whether she was hitchhiking or
whether she had set it up with someone
else at a time to like maybe some he was
in maybe babysitting he was following
her that's what some people said some
people thought she had like a tandem
driver that was ahead of her behind a
convoy and then picked her up why she
didn't want any help from triple-a or
the cops yeah and then took her
somewhere else some people say they took
her there was another boyfriend maybe
maybe that's what it was
could have been you know there's a
million things but then but then how
does another boyfriend explain how she
died right has he just met her and he
she just met him and he was a he was a
psycho yeah I mean it could have been
that it could have been that she just
like was drunk and she wandered off and
froze to death who know yeah the sea
animals got her and the animals got who
knows so it's like it's just this really
really weird case and nobody is really
sure what the [__] happened to her and
she's still gone all these years later
so yeah look up the more amuri case it's
very fascinating and there's a lot of
like I said crazy conspiracy theories
about it that I didn't even mention
because they're too stupid okay so for
the last case I wanted to talk about and
I guess I will have time to you know
what's funny is that just came into my
mind you know some people think that you
know wolf if a person dies that you find
the body
you don't always find them well not
always a big country big country and
there's animals one time at the barn we
had a turkey that died so I pulled it
out of the the dead chicken coop where
it was living was living in there with
the chickens the the roosters nearly
whipped my ass over trying to pull that
the dead turn yeah there's a huge turkey
yeah that's half the size of human being
you know that's heavy so I threw it in
the back of the four-wheeler and chucked
it out back what a little country roads
at the farm that was there he knows that
dr. Mann's house yeah so I said well
come back and get it
look forgot about it yeah next day
though I said well you know it sucks
feeding the horses you know I said Oh
dead turkey yes it I forgot about that
dead turkey so this is first thing in
the morning so go over there where I
left that dead Turkey and there was a
trace that did turn some feathers
yeah that was it and yeah and even rode
around the perimeter you know looking
into the wood line there's been no way
to find that turkey
no no they ripped it up yeah and I don't
even know what got it Bobcats could have
gotten it possums
there's raccoons and a combination of
all of them too you know
well yeah they all wanted a piece they
all take so much Thanksgiving for
everybody and it just it just gets ass
it just gets passed down the food chain
yeah and even the bones a lot of those
bones I think are you probably know
there's marrow in there that smells like
crunch em up and a human is a bird
a human isn't that big yeah
the animals leave that yeah I mean you
know like I said some people if you
disappear in the woods or any bees you
know they'll never find your library
Leslie if you're not buried it yeah
they'll find some serial killer kills
because they bury him animals can't get
to him right so they find the skeleton
it's almost better to leave it out yeah
but they'll find the skull of rosette
they'll find the skull eventually yeah
they won't eat a skull usually but yeah
so this last case this actually happened
in 2000 and this was actually a dude his
name was Emma Quinn and he worked at
Walmart he worked in the electronics
department now with him working at
Walmart was his friend named Robert
Owens you know they both worked there
they played pool they did that kind of
[__] now evidently this was early
January 2000 now
zebb had been wanting to buy a car so
Robert says him oh I know this guy
that's selling the kind of car you want
or whatever like after work you know
follow me to the guy's house and we'll
check it out so they do that now the two
guys were seen on surveillance footage
at a convenience store they're buying
cokes or whatever now later on
zebb got a page because this was 2000 I
guess people still had those and all he
said to Robert he flashed his headlights
at Robert and got him to pull over and
then he said you know I I have to take
this call so he went to a payphone he
made the phone call and then he came
back and he was all freaking out in
fluster he's like I gotta go I gotta go
now as he pulled out evidently he hit
Roberts truck like while he was in his
rush to get out after that zebb
disappeared now this is where the
weirdness starts later on that night
Robert Owens was in a hospital with a
head injury and fractured ribs he said
that it was from another accident not
where the one where Zeb had hit his
truck but there was no car accident
report filed with police
okay so Zeb is missing his mom reports
him missing the next day now two days
after he disappeared someone say
that they were Zeb called the Walmart
and said I'm sick I can't come in now
the person who took the phone call was
like that does not sound like Zeb's
voice so he was suspicious to me
reported it now turned out that the
phone call was traced to a factory where
Robert Owens worked
now Robert Owens said oh well Zeb asked
me to call in sick for him right so I
did because he's my buddy or whatever
there was also this woman that Zeb knew
named misty Taylor and apparently he had
kind of a thing for her but she already
had a boyfriend now this boyfriend was
allegedly abusive so some people have
speculated that maybe the abusive
boyfriend killed Zeb I don't know
I don't think that's what happened the
boyfriends name is Wesley Smith now the
another weird thing too is that the page
that Zeb got that night that he
disappeared they traced that page to the
home of Zeb's aunt whose name was ina
new stick I think I'm pronouncing her
loose tisha poor thing uh pronouncing
that the weird thing was that she said
she didn't call him and that she wasn't
even home that night she said I was at a
friend's house eating dinner now the
friend's house that she was at the
friend was the mother of misty Taylor
the girl that Zeb was into and was
allegedly trying to get away from her
abusive boyfriend okay but so the aunt
says she didn't make this phone call now
she said that that night that the that
the page was sent that someone had
broken into her house but not stolen
anything they just moved things around
so I don't know a couple days after the
disappearance
somebody left zebb's car which was a
Mazda Protege in the parking lot of the
little pigs barbecue that was next to
the hospital where's my
the cars headlights were on someone had
drawn a pair of lips and two exclamation
points on the back window with lipstick
and inside the car was a live labrador
puppy hmm there were also a bunch of
drink bottles that was a jacket in there
that did not belong to Zeb there was a
hotel keycard that could not be traced
and various other things now the car was
you know they try to get forensic
evidence from but nothing really came of
it now somebody said that they had seen
a girl driving that Mazda Protege and
that it looked like misty Taylor so now
the mom is pretty sure that Zeb is dead
that somebody killed him she's like
because he didn't have any money he
didn't have his contact lens solution he
didn't have any of his stuff so it's not
like he just took off or anything like
that now the weird thing about this is
that fifteen years after Zeb disappeared
Robert Owens the friend at the Walmart
yeah he was arrested for murdering
Kristi showing or Schenn which I think
her name is she was on the Food Network
Star season 8 or something like that she
was one of the contestants okay he
killed her she was pregnant at the time
her and her husband
Wow like they arrested him for that he
was a contractor I guess there was like
no motive so I don't know if he was like
a serial killer
apparently he said that he ran over the
husband but he wouldn't say how he
killed the woman they found the remains
of her and her husband in his stove
sanctum I don't know it's like weird I
don't know that's all it says like I
said they give you these details they
don't tell a pretty tiny X please
but yeah so evidently he killed them on
March 12 well you know what then that
would probably explain some of the weird
things about the disappearance of his
friend because there's no motive or
anything well maybe the motive was just
to eat the guy maybe he was a cannibal
yeah he just says you know that guy you
know he tastes good yeah I'm gonna try
that out let's eat this guy and maybe he
ate him over a period a few days and
just then left it could be because they
never did find him now he ate him with a
nice Chianti and some fava beans
so so oh is he actually did get
convicted for the murder of the Food
Network lady and her husband now because
of this crime being unearthed they kind
of went back and reinvestigated like the
disappearance of zebb Quinn now I think
he has been indicted I don't know if
he's been arrested but he has been
indicted for the disappearance of zebb
Quinn that he possibly killed him they
never found a body
now they they go through they dug
through all of the site and everything
like that and they found a bunch of
weird [__] like all they'll say is they
found fabric leather fragments which I
guess maybe is belts or nothing like
that and then they found an unknown
white powder substance
I think numerous plastic bags containing
possibly pulverized lime
yes so they don't know if their bones if
he just like ate him and crushed him up
and buried him under concrete or
something like that right yeah he
they've had an indictment returned and
that was recently that was just in July
I think he's a cannibal so he might be
yeah so that whole thing although I'm
still weirded out by like some of the
details like what's the deal with the
car with the puppy and every and by the
way the puppies find an investigator
adopted the puppy so it's it's okay
because I know people worry about the
condition he wanted to give the car back
because admit was it was set up it was
evidence that could be used against him
and possibly maybe the dog was with him
maybe maybe his buddy picked that dog up
I don't know how weird that he left it
like across from where the mom marked
and and that somebody had seen a girl
driving that car I don't know it's just
there's so much [__] maybe he has a
female accomplice maybe he did yeah
maybe they were those fours I'm just
gonna let it rest Jenny I don't have any
ideas on it I kind of do feel like he
probably killed that guy but there's
like guys there's still a lot of [__]
that doesn't had up about it right but
yeah and another thing is I have to
assume that they know a lot more than
what they're telling us well yeah
there's a bunch of evidence that they're
holding because like I said they always
give you these tantalizing
yeah they don't tell you their body in
the stove I'm like wow there's it on
what does that mean those authors aren't
going trial and litigate yeah this is a
candid yeah and Becky is that so they
can't tell you everything they know
right it may end up being once you have
all the data all the information it may
end up being very a very mundane
sounding Scituate well it usually is
it's only just the mystery that kind of
runs it see because there's missing
parts of the story yeah exactly
but anyway we hope you enjoyed this look
into several creepy disappearances I'm
actually glad that we had time to get to
all of them because I was kind of
excited yeah they're pretty good I know
there were next time we got it we got to
do it another haunting episode yeah we
got it well I wanted to do um we got it
I gotta get that last season what does
the season seven yeah I wanted a new
haunted Victorian and maybe Sally's
house okay I don't know I have a couple
episodes I want to buy the season 7 DVD
well get on that and they're on season 9
that they're not I think they're doing
season well yeah they don't have my
collection complete get your connection
yeah I've only seen we've only seen like
the season 8 & 9 ones like once probably
yeah maybe we should go back and looking
at me on some of them we might have
missed yeah because some of that some I
remember a few of the new ones being
kind of compelling yeah not most of them
not though I remember a couple of them
being good we'll get we'll get them
there hey even doing a stupid one might
be fun well the stupid ones are really
fun to do especially if they're like
ludicrously yeah like day trippers I
think day trippers was the one with the
kids in the cemetery yeah and her mom
was a witch yeah that was very silly
yeah but anyway we're getting to the end
of the show and we'll let it ride well
you know yes that's how you do that's
got Tom rolls yeah he lets things regice
let it ride so if you liked the show
remember to Like share and subscribe and
all of that stuff also check out our
patreon at patreon calm
13 o'clock podcasts and give us a small
monthly donation you'll get a lot of
neat stuff and you know we came up with
this idea that maybe people that that
were patrons that were paying more than
$10 a month that we could run a
commercial of their choice yeah actually
we just he said he thought of it
yesterday but he just told it to me like
during the commercial break on this show
and I was like wow that's a really good
idea so yeah we actually might start
doing the offering that is Jenny true
Jenny can actually make a commercial and
anything you know you can make a
commercial and everything we can do
voiceovers did good little graphics or
whatever and will actually give you a
commercial spot right there on our
commercials yeah and so if you have your
own business you want to promote or your
own site you know we'll do it that way
yeah that's actually really good and we
already have some people that are paying
more than $10 yeah so if you're paying
more than $10 a month you want a
commercial contact this will get you in
so well I'll update the patreon page -
yeah reflect that new perk and this
added incentive yes to become a patron
yeah yeah and also if you don't want to
give a monthly donation or if you don't
like patreon for some reason because I
know some people don't then go to our
blog at 13 o'clock podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a little
PayPal donation link over there in the
sidebar so you could just give a
one-time donation if you want to do that
that would be really nice and also what
else
don't forget this weekend spooky Empire
come down and see us if you're in the
Orlando area and say hi to us and buy a
book and get your picture taken and then
autograph and all that and also this is
kind of your last chance to set in any
Halloween stories that you have for our
Halloween episode and also don't forget
to check out my book the faceless
villain which is out in print an e-book
and will be out an audiobook in probably
about two weeks maybe two weeks three
weeks something like that yeah at the
very outside and that'll do it for
episode 62 see you guys next Tuesday so
long
[Music]
under down to
first up to
[Music]
[Applause]
now I don't see you
[Music]
you